we rely primarily on vision so we do
have instead is we have eight cameras
that are pointed in the 360 around the
car and we obtain video streams from all
those cameras and we parse them using
neural networks and we stitched it up
into a view of what's around us in three
dimensions in 360 so this is kind of
more of what we see what the car seats
at every single frame and we're trying
to stitch it up so I'm now going to go
into the computer vision problem and
what's kind of necessary to cut this to
work now we're in a multi task workshop
so first I will talk about just a single
task and make the point that even for
one task this can actually be very
difficult problem if you want this to
work all the time so 97% accuracy is not
good enough you actually really need
high 99.9 percent accuracy for this to
be a shil to be actually safe to deploy
so as an example even the basic visual
recognition tasks like object detection
we're putting bounding boxes around cars
this is very difficult if you actually
want to ship this and make it safe
because cars don't just look like that
they actually have a massive variety to
them as there are cars with science cars
that look odd cars on cars bikes on cars
cement trucks cars with Falcon wings
boats and other objects a cars that take
up the entire a field of the view of the
camera and so even your basic abundant
box abstraction actually just breaks
cars with appendages and excavators cars
upside down cars with trailers trailers
and then of course heavily occluded cars
so for example in parking lots you you
just a very heavy occlusions it's very
difficult to deal with front with a very
naive approach to object detection so
even in the process of getting a single
task to work there's a ton that goes
into what is the architecture we're
already printing or dilations are using
a ResNet or dense net or what is the
architecture look like what does your
last function look like what object
detection and technique are using but
also not just for the model but the data
set itself we have to iterate on the
data set and we do that in an iterative
fashion and something that I call the
data engine so you which is a process by
which you iteratively build your data
set so you have a network that you've
trained on some data set v-0 and then
you train your network deploy it and you
have mechanisms by which she noticed
that the network is misbehaving or
previous inaccuracies and you sort
source those examples annotate them
correctly and incorporate them in the
training set and you spin this data
engine loop over
to actually get this task to work really
well and we don't just do this for one
task we do this for many tasks so let me
try to go into how this gets very crazy
very fast and the core issue is that you
there's actually like a ton of things
you might want to know about the
environment if you're trying to drive so
as an example in this random image of
the residential neighborhood you don't
just want to know about the cars but
there's of course a ton of things you
want to know you want to know about the
static objects not just in moving
objects you want to know about the road
size and what they're telling you you
want to know about the overhead signs
next to the traffic lights and they tell
you about whether or not you can do you
turn or anything like that you want to
know about the traffic lights in all
their state and you have to handle all
the variety of those traffic lights the
lane lines which at the flow of traffic
the road markings that tell you what you
can and can't do in any lane the curbs
that tell you about where you may or may
not want to move if you want to not
damage your vehicle the crosswalks that
hint at the behavior of pedestrians in
the vicinity and lots of environment
tags as an example like is it are you in
a residential neighborhood are you in a
tunnel are you coming up to a tollbooth
all those predictions are also kind of
binary classification problems for
example that we solve for every single
image there are a ton of things you
might want to know it about every single
scenes it is not an exhaustive list it's
also a bit of a cartoon these are not
exactly our tasks but it just gives you
a sense of there's there's about 50
volts or so tasks that we simultaneously
work on in the team and even though I've
put only a single task here says moving
objects there's actually lots of sub
tasks for moving objects because I want
to know a ton about all those objects is
it a pedestrian or bicyclists are more
cyclists at the cup truck is it a truck
is it a bus all those things have
repercussions on your driving policy and
your expectations about how these things
by move is this able is an ambulance a
firetruck is it a police car are there
sirens on
is it a construction vehicle is the left
blinker on right blinker on are the rear
lights on is the car cutting in it
doesn't look like it's parked all those
things are subtasks that you might want
to know all of these are independent
predictions that you must predict on
every single car all of them have their
own data engine and so the scope of this
problem very quickly just becomes quite
quite daunting so that's kind of what
we're faced with we make about 20 or 30
tasks and every one of those has sub
tasks so you end up with basically 100
sub tasks that we all have to solve
simultaneously enough to make work
really well to very high accuracy
requirements before we can actually
deploy it so I'll talk a little bit
about some of the struggles and some of
the way that we're approaching these
problems so from the architectural
standpoint first obviously we are
putting in some image and we'd like to
understand a lot of things about it but
there are there's a large design space
as to what goes into the black box that
makes this network so at one end of the
spectrum you might imagine that every
single task for example could get its
own network an independent network and
all these different choices
architectural will have their own pros
of pros and cons so in this case for
example if you separate out every single
task to its own network then some of the
downsides are that as an example this
will be very expensive at test time
we've refined that compute budget on the
car we want to run this at high frame
rates to ensure safety and so of course
you might not have the computational
budget to actually run 30 different
tasks 30 different comments that every
single frame for every single camera
moreover there's no feature sharing and
it's kind of a setup and so if your task
one of the tasks as an example might not
have enough data then you're going to
actually over fit and but what is nice
about this and I'm going to go a little
bit more into the team workflow of how
you actually develop these networks is
that the decouples functionality so if
you only want to improve on moving
objects as an example then you retrain
your network of moving objects and
someone can iterate on that and try out
a different detector since like that and
you know that you're not changing or
regressing some of the other tasks so
you can sort of iterate on one thing
holding everything else constant and you
don't have to re-evaluate the entire
system as much on the other end of the
extreme we could try to have all of
these tasks be separate heads very
lightweight heads on top of a single
shared backbone so this is kind of on
the other end of a stream in this case
this would be significantly cheaper at
test time because this backbone is
basically multitasking and all those
things but there are some downsides so
as an example all these tasks will now
write for the same shared capacity
sometimes they fight sometimes they
actually help each other there's
complicated binary relationship there
that I will go into but the downside is
that this fully couples the
functionality so if you're just trying
to improve your moving objects detector
then of course
maybe you're just fine-tuning the last
piece without touching the backbone but
if you if those features are not good
enough and you actually have to touch
the backbone the sudden you have to
continue training all the other tasks
it's something yet to revalidate all the
other tasks so just couples the
problem and makes it much more
challenging to actually evaluate so
there's a massive kind of space of
in-betweens of the architectures in
between this one and the first one that
I showed and exactly how you lay out the
architecture and how you plug everything
together is there's a large unknown
there so you can try to explore this
manually or you can try some approaches
that have been developed sort of that
are automatic typically these approaches
like this paper Auto D plot that has
come out recently they're trying to find
the optimal architecture in the NASA net
kind of style for semantic segmentation
problem and so they find where should
the different operations be how are they
hardly plugging together whereas the
encoder decoder have you up sample and
all those different things so you can
imagine running something like that in
our setting but it gets a bit more
complicated because we don't just have
one task we have multiple tasks so
exactly how do you layout this
architecture how much feature sharing is
there maybe the first three layers are
shared but from then on they split off
into a different networks how much
capacity do you allocate to any single
different sub piece of this network it's
it's not really obvious how you actually
go about exploring all these different
choices there are papers that recently
have started to come out a row that
actually study these multi task settings
and all these different tasks they're
typically very heterogeneous so some of
them will help each other and some of
them will hurt each other and so there's
complicated binary matrix here in this
paper of which tasks seems to be helping
each other in which tasks I seem to
fight so as an example for us moving
objects and traffic lights typically do
not share too many features so we see
that they fight but some other tasks
actually help each other so when you
train moving objects with a second task
the accuracy on the moving objects could
actually improve so what they find in
this paper is that they study basically
the problem of how many backbones do I
have and where do I put the heads and
how should I allocate the heads to the
backbones to come up with the optimal
performance and they study this as a
function of your computational budget so
if you don't have too many resources
computationally then you would have a
single backbone and you would hang all
the heads on top of that single backbone
but then on the very bottom let me try
to a point this is kind of ambitious but
as I can't see but on the very bottom
they find that the optimal assignment if
you do have more resources is that you
actually have independent backbones and
you place some of the heads of
Beckham's but there's a discrepancy
between a train and a test kind of
training and inference there so as an
example one of the backbones could be
trained on five tasks but then at test
time you only intend to run three of
those five tasks on that backbone the
other two tasks are only there to create
better features for that backbone which
is really interesting so we also find
similar things except we have like 30 or
50 tasks and we try to study some of
these relationships but it's a very
complicated but we do see these
complicated interactions it's not
obvious how you actually study them in
this paper they propose a few few ideas
there now where it gets even more
complicated for us is that we don't just
have a single viewport a viewpoint we
actually have eight cameras as I
mentioned and all of those cameras as
you might imagine are just different
viewpoints but they're all made they all
have cars they all have potentially
other objects like traffic lights and so
on and so you might imagine that you
actually might want to share features
across those different viewpoints so for
us it looks a little bit like this
potentially where we might have some of
the first layers that are shared across
all the other viewpoints because all the
viewpoints will have edges and piece and
little wheel shapes and stuff like that
but then they start to split off later
in the network and eventually on a per
camera you might actually split off all
the different tasks and so this is
potentially what that network could look
like and then the other dimension to all
of this of course is that not only do we
have tasks that are per camera or per or
use multiple cameras but we have tasks
that potentially could use context
across time so you have to imagine
taking this beast of a network stamping
it out across time and if you're using
something like a recurring all that or
something you would be sharing features
across the time dimension but
effectively your network ends up looking
maybe something like this it's a bit of
a beast and then what's going on is that
you have all these different tasks that
this network is simultaneously juggling
so as an example maybe I take a batch of
static objects on a narrow camera which
is one facing forward and then what that
does is it subsamples the part of this
network and only on that part of the
network are we doing a forward backward
and an update and the other parts of the
network are held still and then maybe we
have a different batch and in this case
it's a batch of path prediction
I'm not going to go into the details of
that prediction but this
tasks actually could be a prediction
that is based on not just one camera but
three cameras giving yourself a bit more
of a wider field of view and so in this
case we subsample a different portion of
the network and train that and then we
try to train the cutting detector and
the cutting detector might benefit from
temporal information of how these cars
are moving over time and so you might
activate again a different part of this
network so while you're training you're
always sampling these different tasks
and sampling this network and training
different pieces of it and they're there
sharing some of the features in
complicated ways that are sometimes
difficult to do honestly like derive as
to what they should be so there's a lot
of intuition that goes into it and a lot
of experimentation of course so those
are just the architectural
considerations and we have a ton of
considerations with respect to loss
functions so as you might imagine all
these different tasks will kind of
mathematically plug into the same final
loss and that's what's being back
propagated now when you actually look
into the literature of how people deal
with these very large and multi task
settings I'm just picking a random paper
here this this pen optics imitation
paper that I found a few weeks ago maybe
so they're doing this simultaneously
both something that looks like object
detection but also something that looks
like semantic segmentation and you see
you have these lambdas here and those
lambdas are high parameters they are
task weights so how much do you weigh
the object detection part and the
somatic segmentation part and typically
what you find in these papers is that
there's a large grid search going on
over those task weights so it's a brute
force solution trying to identify what
those whites should be to get the best
mean average precision or something like
that and this works if you have two of
them it does not work if you have say
hundred of them which is what we do have
and so you have to do something
different a lot of it typically relies
on intuition I'd love to see other
approaches but the difficult aspect of
this is that the heterogeneity of these
tasks is not just on the architectural
level because some tasks might need for
example much more dilation than others
but this heterogeneity is also on the on
the level of losses and that's because
some tasks might be in different scales
so their losses could be classification
or regression so different scales of
these loss functions would have
different task weights potentially some
tasks are much more important so as an
example moving objects tasks would be
much more important than the road
Kings tasks if I don't correctly predict
road markings I might take the wrong
turn but at least I'm not going to
potentially crash into something some
tasks are much easier than others so
what we see is that some tasks just
converged very easily and very
immediately but some tasks have a
massive amount of variety like moving
objects they will take a long time to
train
conversely say like a road markings task
if you're trying to identify a left
arrow that left arrow will always take
on a very similar appearance so it
trains much faster sometimes had much
more data than others or have much more
noise and so this has repercussions on
the regularization strength of the
different sub parts of this graph so if
I have a some task that has very few
examples then of course I can't afford
to train a very thick head for it or I
can't afford to use too many parameters
there or I might want to regularize that
piece of the network much more strongly
so it's not just about the weights but
also the regularization coefficients for
all these different tasks and there's no
there's no like real language in the
community as to how we how we sort of
understand or measure all these
different components for tasks like what
are the things that matter the amount
noise the amount of data set some kind
of an importance that maybe could be
tuned by the person but how you actually
come up in a principled way with these
task weights I think is like quite
unknown based on what I've seen so far
so those are sort of the statics of the
problem the architecture in the loss
function there's a lot that goes also
into some of the training dynamics so
what makes this hard so as an example we
are trying to get a traffic lights to
color to work well if you are just
naively sampling your datasets from the
fleet then you might find that most of
the traffic lights will always have red
or green color and so it will be very
unlikely for you to run into orange or
say blue or something like that so you
might be in a setting where you have a
million red and green and you only have
like 50,000 of orange or 10,000 of blue
after you've tried really hard and so
what you do typically in that case is in
academia what you'll see a standard is
you might want to start to massage your
batches so it's not just about the task
weights but you can also massage the
batches and make sure that you have some
representation of all these rare classes
speak due to the label imbalance inside
your badge now this oversampling or this
tuning of these batches doesn't just
happen on a single batch level serve
like within attack
like traffic lights but it also happens
across tasks because some of these tasks
that I mentioned are much easier to
train and train much faster so as an
example the road markings task we might
only want to sample a batch of road
markings every tenth cycle but moving
objects we might want to sample more
often to Train and so we have a schedule
for batches that is both on the level of
tasks but also inside a task we have a
schedule of batches and examples that we
pick there so here's our data set as an
example in a cartoon setting we have
rows which are different images columns
which are different tasks and then X
indicates a presence of a label for that
task and that image as you'll note this
is a very sparse array typically in
academia what I'm seeing is that these
are almost always assumed to be dense so
each image has all the supervision this
is not the case for us because you have
to remember there's a data engine for
every single tasks so they'll he'll have
their own sort of instances as you end
up with a very sparse array there's over
sampling across both tasks but also
within a task there's all kinds of
complicated over sampling and what you
end up with typically as something along
the lines of sample a task from your
scheduled sample a batch for that task
do a forward and backward and do an
update and there's some of the issues
that you run into as an example and
these are somewhat subtle is that
suppose I take a batch of moving objects
and I did all this work of the forward
pass and I do the moving objects head
and I'm gonna do the backward pass so
suppose that this example that I just
forwarded also happens to have a label
for static objects so since I've done
all this work of the forward pass I
might as well want to amortize that work
and actually train on the static objects
if I have that label so should I train
that component or not so you'd like to
amortize the computation and train on it
but if you do you're actually messing
with the over sampling ratios that
you've specified per task so that
example you're sort of messing with the
distributions of your matches and some
non-intuitive ways so so what I'm trying
to get at is and I do want to go into
full detail but the scheduling of this
is somewhat complex and there's a lot of
open questions here the other kind of
interesting aspects of this are you will
know about early stopping when you're
trying to get a model to work really
well you monitor the test loss and/or do
validation loss and you take your model
whenever your validation loss is lowest
let's at least
that works well if you have one task
what happens when you have 200 tasks
where do you take your model I don't
know
so your plots will typically look like
this in tensor board and now you're
trying to get your model and obviously
some tasks will over fit much earlier
than others because they are easier or
they have more data or less data and so
this heterogeneity again is pretty
tricky to to deal with and how do you
now manipulate the tasks or the over
sampling rates or the task weights or
the regularization so that ideally these
end up in the same spot so you can just
cut a clean model it's not it's not
obvious the last pieces that I wanted to
go into just mostly for entertainment
actually is with respect to the teamwork
flow around how you actually collaborate
on a network like this as I described
this is kind of a beast of a network it
multitasks so many things and we have a
finite team and this team is dispersed
across the network and collaborating on
this network at the same time so maybe
there's we have this notion of a task
owner so someone's working up on the
moving objects someone is working on
static objects someone is turning on
traffic lights and the architecture
there someone is messing with the lost
function for traffic lights and two
interns are working on the architecture
on the bottom so the tricky thing is
that and I haven't seen this ever before
is you have this large network but you
have say 10 20 people collaborating on
this network and they all own different
sub parts of this network and what does
that look like in practice if you have a
code base of course you have git and you
pull requests and commits and and so on
but these people are collaborating on
the neural network and this is all
coupled functionality and it's really
not obvious how you iterate on networks
where multiple people are simultaneously
changing the tasks the weights the data
itself and everything is is moving so
just a few interesting kind of things
that have happened in a team as an
example I walk around that's me on the
bottom left over there and I say hi
traffic traffic lights task owner if you
could make traffic lights work a bit
better that would be great
and the traffic lights and there are
many tips and tricks to actually getting
your tasks the one that you own and you
want to work very well to work well so
the traffic lights owner has an idea and
they go to the configuration file where
you list all the different tasks
and as I mentioned we have different
oversampling ratios for different tasks
so you just go to the traffic lights and
you see your oversample as just one so
you make that two and that means that
your task will be trained more and that
means your network will work better on
your traffic lights tasks and then you
say hey can you prove my commits and a
random person says ok and moving objects
person gets upset what's going on here
because their tasks will be starved of
resources and the capacity of the
network is finite and so suddenly this
is not okay so this is a very obvious
one the team is caught on we don't try
to manipulate oversampling ratios too
much but there are many more devious
ways of making your tasks work better so
as an example you go to your traffic
light loss and you just multiply your
loss by 10 let's make your tat this
makes your task work better potentially
but it's so it's not illegal but it's
definitely frowned upon ok so I mean the
higher point being that there's finite
capacity to go around and a lot of
people are trying to simultaneously get
their their tasks to work well but there
are many ok ways of doing that and some
of them are caused political drama I
would say in the team that and I have I
have to somehow like allocate capacity
to the tasks but there's no easy ways of
doing that it's not really task awaits
it's not over sampling so I don't really
have language to describe how to
correctly
allocate capacity to tasks and
interesting weights to them another
interesting aspect that we've noticed is
very often it is the case that you have
all these different tasks they
simultaneously coexist in the network
you're pretty happy with everything
except for this one task that needs that
it's kind of misbehaving in a certain
way you want to change that sub task and
so it has some kind of a failure mode
that you want to fix so because you
don't want to touch the full network
because everything is validated and
signed off you might have this idea that
ok I will just what I'll do is I will
just fine-tune this little piece of this
network and I will make this work a bit
better just by fine tuning that small
piece I'm not touching any of the other
tasks nothing has to be revalidated and
so on and I'll just try to improve this
in isolation so basically you find you
never adjust your task and you leave
everything unchanged do you create a new
model and you might want to go with that
so what was the worst that could happen
is the follow
so what happens is you end up with a
very complicated lineage of models where
a person took a base model and
fine-tuned it and then a different
person took their model and fine-tuned
something else and then someone
functions something on top of that and
somehow fine-tuned something on the
wrong base model and now because the
model has changed so now there's a
complicated chain of fine tunings that
people have performed and this this
doesn't work it starts to look something
like that
so you really have to and of course the
worst of it is is that some of these
models then become not reproduce able so
what you can end up with and this has
happened to our team is you end up with
very good models that have gone through
non-intuitive chain of fine tunings you
end up with a very good model that you
can't reproduce and that is the worst
because you retrain from scratch and you
you're regressing some performance that
you've had there so it's very appealing
to want to do this but we found for
example because of the workflow that you
actually just can't you can't get away
with that it's not a good idea
so in summary just some of the things I
talked about of course we have so many
different tasks there are many
considerations to the architecture to
the loss function there train dynamics
and how to deal with all the
regularization and then lock task
weights there's no language that I'm
aware of in academia to talk about the
heterogeneity of these tasks and
different properties thereof and how to
make everything work with early stopping
and stuff like that and also the most
fascinating component to me is when you
have networks that are means
simultaneously worked on by 20 people
what does that look like
where are the what is the etiquette and
then what where are the the tips and
tricks and rules of thumb for how to how
to work with these architectures so that
everything works ok great thank you
[Applause]
[Music]